caroline de camaret il est très
difficile de se déplacer dans bruxelles
aujourd'hui pour cause la capitale belge
accueille donc ce sommet de l'otan mais
aussi vous l'évoquiez ceux du g7 et du
conseil européen on va parler sanctions
économiques est ce qu'on peut attendre
de ces deux rendez vous cet après midi
alors vous savez ici au conseil européen
s'est à nouveau ouverts ça a été fermée
aux journalistes dans leur entièreté
pendant le coc vide pendant donc de très
longs mois et là on en attend 1500 c'est
deux fois plus que d'habitude en raison
de la présence évidemment de joe biden
qui va entamer je vous le disais à 16h30
ce conseil il va beaucoup s'agir cette
fois-ci de la réponse économique bien
sûr des européens et les européens leur
problème c'est la dépendance à 40% des
importations de gaz russe à 25% des
importations de pétrole à 46% du charbon
et pour s'en débarrasser et bien ils
pensent à plusieurs solutions ils vont
se tourner bien sûr vers de nouveaux
figurent ni soeur dont les américains
évidemment très important pour veux
qu'ils puissent exporter vers nos
terminaux vers des terminaux européen
lors gaz naturel liquéfié mais il va
falloir aussi peut-être penser comme les
prix s'envolent à des achats de gaz en
commun pour faire baisser les prix donc
par la commission européenne comme on
l'a fait vous souvenez finalement pour
les vaccins en quelque sorte et ça ça va
être bien sûr discuter ardemment
certains parlent aussi de plafonner le
prix de l'électricité et du gaz mais
évidemment cela ne fait pas du tout la
sphère des plus libres échangistes
d'entre d'entre les européens bref une
discussion d'avenir aussi est engagée
sur notre dépendance énergétique notre
mix énergétique
et puis aussi dans l'immédiat eh bien si
si vladimir poutine menace de faire
payer en roubles son gaz par exemple
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans l'immédiat si
des facto en quelque sorte il nous coupe
le gaz et bien tout cela est sujet à
discussion la président de la commission
a quand même voulu rassurer pour ce qui
est de cet hiver nous avons les réserves
suffisants pour distribuer à tous les
européens merci beaucoup caroline de
camaret et l'on suivra bien sûr ces deux
sommets cet après midi avec vous en dire